oh there's been an attack on a prominent
Shia Shrine in Iran it happened in
Shiraz in the south of the country at
least one person has been killed and
seven injured State media say the attack
was carried out by two people one has
been arrested the other escaped
all right Dolce Jabari joins us now live
from Tehran so they say one person has
been arrested as a motive for this
attack being suggested
no Tammy as we speak officials are
questioning one of the gunmen who they
have arrested and have in custody
according to officials he's being
interrogated at the moment in the
southern city of Shiraz in fars Province
now according to local officials two
gunmen stormed Cheryl Shrine in Shiraz
which is one of the most well-known
tourist attractions in the country
around 7 PM this evening and they opened
fire on the people in the shrine now
officials responded quickly and they
managed to arrest one of the Suspects on
the scene and the second man has escaped
them The Manhunt is underway officials
say that they have managed to secure the
area of the shrine and all the shops in
the vicinity of this Shrine have been
closed down now according to officials
they have managed to control the
situation and they at least seven people
have been transported to hospital there
status is not known yet we understand
that the interior Minister has also been
in touch with the governor of farce
Province and has ordered an
investigation into the incident as
quickly as possible to try and figure
out actually what transpired
and also there have been attacks on
Shiraz shrines before right there was a
one in last year in October is a patent
emerging here
well this is the second time in less
than a year that an attack has been
carried out on the same Shrine last
October three gunmen storm Shrine and
they opened fire where they killed 13
people and injured dozens now that was
something that later the attack was
claimed by the isil group and the uh
into the security apparatus in Iran said
that there was a network of people
involved in carrying out that attack
three of the gunmen one of them was
killed on site and two other men were
tried and a sentenced to that they were
just executed in public not too far from
Shrine Insurance Where They carried out
the attack in July the other three men
are serving prison terms in Iran
anywhere from 5 to 25 years but these
attacks are not that common but the
pattern here for this specific location
is certainly calls for alarm for
officials no one has claimed
responsibility for this attack yet but
the security apparatuses in the country
are going to be looking exactly how
something like this this could have
happened twice at the same location in
less than a year they have been a very
adamant that they are in charge and in
control of the borders of Iran but they
say that there are certainly Powers at
play that want to destabilize Iran and
have said that foreign Nationals have
been part of these attacks at least in
planning one and as far as we understand
now today in the attack that took place
at the one person they have in custody
is believed to be a foreign National we
have no idea which country he is from
but we're waiting to get more
information from officials all right
thanks so much Giovanni